how are you Kirk I'm Craig dan how you
doing what do you make of what I had to
say about Ohio State you know I think
there's I said during the broadcast this
is different than Ohio State going up to
iowa city last year and JT Barrett's
having a tough night no state getting
bombed they were able to kind of get
back to the drawing board and kind of
clean some things up and said it was a
veteran leaders like JT Barrett Billy
price this was team that you know when
all of us decide so that was going on
before the season Urban Meyer comes back
and there's issues there if you really
have watched them there's their defense
linebacker play to safety clay has been
very erratic you Nick those who decide
to leave the team who was a captain of
the team and you know his dad kind of
made it sound like he wasn't going to
come back to mid-december
anyway so he wanted to focus on getting
ready and and so you can't run the
football the offensive line they could
say whatever they want but the line is
struggling but they could 72 times
against Purdue so I think there's a lot
there
and I think Urban Meyer on her percent
agree with you Urban Meyer he's not
going to talk about it publicly you know
two or three weeks ago he took a knee
you know he kind of grabbed his head and
he says he's been having headaches
he doesn't look this the way he's looked
since he's been I don't have a state
where he said listen up I'm gonna take
this whole iost a job after when I went
to Atlanta I'm gonna keep my priorities
straight family first
not gonna get out of whack and if set if
you watch him on the sidelines he's been
back he looks just I'm bored I've used
as Angliss he looks frustrated he looks
very emotional and erratic and his team
right now you're gonna find out what
they're what they're made out of because
like I said you lost I will ask you you
had leaders to kick you back you lose
this year we'll see what how they
respond but they've got they got some
big problems can they still make the
playoffs if they've gone from number two
to number 11 what has to happen for Ohio
State
well if I think first of all I gotta
worry about tackling and running a
football before they worry about the
playoffs but the reality is they get a
bye week this week to get healthy got
Nebraska at home they go up these
Lansing they go to Maryland and you know
how things are if they are able to play
better the way they're playing right now
they could lose to Nebraska who can
score a lot of points but if they play
better and play the way they're capable
then I think they if they win those
games against Nebraska Michigan State in
Maryland there's a really good chance
that you're looking at the winner of the
Ohio State Michigan game winning the Big
Ten East and then getting into the Big
Ten championship and they would have a
shot then if okay how it sits right now
you've got Alabama yeah Clemson yet
Notre Dame the potential argument could
be the winner of the big 12 championship
against the winner of the Big Ten
championship if it's Ohio State or
Michigan trying to say that they deserve
to be in there and efficient wins in
Michigan would would probably end up
being the team that would go to a
playoff ball goes from some of their own
fans thinking he can't win the big game
to possibly making a make it a playoff
run best team other than Alabama is who
Clemson okay yeah yeah they're there
they're fine I think they're finally
kind of finding their stride their
defense is really really good especially
up front and you know the quarterback
situation with Kelly Bryant leaving
Trevor Lawrence coming in true freshman
a lot of people raised their eyebrows
about that the Trevor Lawrence is is a
difference maker he's not maybe a to his
level yet the Alabama quarterback but
he's got so much potential he just seems
to be getting better and better each
week with more experience so yeah I
think clearly there's Alabama and
there's Clemson and then there's in my
opinion anyway there's I think there's a
pretty significant gap and then you
start to get to LSU and Notre Dame in
Michigan and and you know from that
point down do you think that if we keep
seeing sort
of Alabama Clemson the next couple of
years then the momentum to open this up
to make it an eight game playoff it is
this going to help build momentum to
change the system once that contract
expires well if you asked me I would say
yes I disagree
Reese would tell you if you want to
change beat up beat these teams like I I
love the idea I I always wanted it to be
just for it said college football's
regular season matters yeah I don't want
us to become March Madness where nobody
cares going to regular season
give me my bracket let's watch the for
three weeks at the end that's football -
every week we're excited about what
what's happening and was that being said
after watching it since 14 2014 I
wouldn't love to see it expanded I'd
love to see it go to six or possibly
eight and have more teams with the sod
to get in there at the end because of
what you're saying
Clemson Alabama it's like a broken
record it's like LeBron just be with the
Cavs and Golden State it's you know
everything else that happens during the
rainy season hurry up and get to LeBron
going up against Golden State that's how
it kind of feels with college football
with our banner in Clemson right now so
I wouldn't have a problem opening this
thing up at all we'll see if it happens
but you know I think that the conference
commissioners have made it pretty clear
that they're gonna stay at four for now
and it's gonna take something pretty big
I think for them to change their minds
he's Kirk Herbstreit from the mothership
on the call Texas Oklahoma State coming
up this Saturday on ABC College GameDay
will be in Jacksonville for Florida
versus Georgia what was it like getting
out of the stadium in West Lafayette on
Saturday night like you said gameday in
the morning and I I stayed from my high
school my boys are in high school down
there my twins or seniors and eclair in
Nashville and so I stayed for their game
hide a night when I flew to Pullman and
got in and I don't I've had some fun
game days over the years but that was as
crazy and festive of an atmosphere
throughout the entire Trillium
the show and after the show and and so I
left that scene which was crazy and flew
about four hours to to West Lafayette
and I said this was not a surprise that
Ohio State lost to put it in August that
Ohio State's potential Iowa game that
they got to be ready for is at Purdue
and Purdue is a team that maybe people
they learn Purdue fans don't really
respect they started the year oh and
three but they've been getting better
the coaches big time Jeff Brohm and I
got a great quarterback rondell Moore
may be the most electrifying player in
the country as a true freshman and and
when they won you saw the scene you know
after the game the entire fan base on
the field one of those moments in
college football I don't try to get out
of there I mean it was it's kind of what
you would expect it's like going back to
UD at the ghetto after the Flyers just
won a huge game you know it's that kind
of scene that makes college football so
unique and they were they were obviously
fired up about that big upset I
mentioned that on this day a couple
years ago mahomes went against Baker
Mayfield in mahomes I think through 72
times what do you I know we look at you
know my homes now and everybody goes oh
I saw all of this greatness here do you
remember the first time do you remember
the first time you saw mahomes and what
your reaction was you know what I do
remember and I thought it was just
another Texas Tech quarterback in a
system throwing the ball around 50 60 70
times and they really think much about
it i I I personally have a hard time
evaluating Texas Tech air raid
quarterbacks and how they're gonna fit
in the NFL and to their credit the NFL
has tweaked as we see with Kansas City
LA Chicago in sort of the cases with
Brady and New England they're tweaking
things and and becoming a little bit
more like college football and well
think about antegrade who grew up in the
West Coast offense for him to recognize
missed into the game but instead of
saying just being hey I'm a West Coast
guy this is my offense he decides to
tweet his system to his quarterbacks
strengths
and the rest is history I mean I'm a I'm
a Bengals fan and I watched that game
last night and we'll just felt bad for
him watching him try to defend the
playmakers around the homes but I would
have never I don't think anybody could
have ever told you that Patrick Mahone
was going to become what he is now in
the NFL because it was so hard to
predict how do these air raid
quarterbacks transition into the NFL
where they're gonna drop back seven
steps in the pocket read defenses you
know and it's not many of them do well
and this guy obviously is is off to just
a brilliant career good stuff Herbie and
thanks for being honest about Patrick
mahomes because now I'm hearing
everybody going on I knew this guy was
gonna be great no nobody knew it no I
mean he was a rookie because people saw
what Kansas City was doing with their
offense but tell me that any difference
between what he was doing and every
single guy over the last eight or ten
years in Texas Tech's offenses AIIMS
it was he deserves a lot of credit
special talent but I think Andy Reed
recognizing that talent and tweaking his
system deserves just as much if not more
credit or adjusting his offense good
stuff Herbie safe travels thanks for
joining us that's at Kirk Herbstreit
ESPN college football analyst for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]